Hales gum bros my name is Peter Pan why
are we sitting on the floor of my stereo
mic might says here I guess we got foot
cam going oh my god yeah we're not
something that why am i without socks
what a great question marks a trap
because that's what you asked because I
got my own socks
Epis are happy socks is a friend from
Sweden they make really cool socks they
asked if I wanted to make some and I'm
like hell yeah
oh yeah it's Christmas this is an
excellent gift to anyone who is a bro or
if you are have a friend who's a bro
give them some socks be like hey you got
ugly feet put these up elf it's cold
also it is called all right I'm gonna
unbox for the foot cam so it looks
better I like the packaging design that
myself
finally I have some merch to be excited
about but Evan
um I'm gonna guess you go for the public
I'm gonna go with the brofist ones I
like these because tonight I like these
guys over the tent and like it looks
cool
what is this take this stupid socks away
yeah to keep your feet away from me okay
this is not why we're doing this oh my
god you saw my butt you this is a butt
cam stop yeah this is cool
I don't know I'm very cool first
challenge is that we're gonna draw with
our feet let me get lazy not tired I'm
slouching okay okay so we have to draw
each other the best way possible
with our feet oh man you you gonna look
so good my dear you're such a beautiful
Italian if we tell them beautiful
goddess all right yeah you're welcome
what is that stop you do dude that looks
like a potato that looks like a testicle
hey nothing right
shut up can you believe her I got your
nose okay I got your nose right okay I
think I got your eyes what the hell is
this oh you got my nose Ryan you got my
nose trying
look at your eyebrows their room their
matching under precisely on fleen yeah
this is terrible any all right who won i
won
there's an arm wrestling game you have
to press as fast as possible is this is
not fair cuz you're you shut fair
because I won't win okay here we go you
ready
hey it's not working you turned it off
[Music]
[Applause]
oh-oh-oh-oh
you're really bad at this
alright so the challenge is we have two
fruits I will open the banana and you
will open the Clementine with your feet
three two one
[Music]
okay come on
no cheating oh wow I got a cramp
I got a cramp my foot oh yeah we're
doing what is wrong with you you told me
to open it and then I won has a long
minute Clements come one fine
all right fine the last challenge right
Oh for this one I gotta change my socks
I really like these ones they're very
cool
they're very spunky psychedelic a
fighting game oh my god so you're on the
left I'm on the right ladies and
gentlemen it's show oh my god this is so
hard
oh oh this is actually working what the
hell okay okay okay okay come on come
from this this is so weird
I'm trying to use combos and advance
move sets now I'm dead wow wow wow look
at mine you can't get out corner yeah
yeah you got problem with Mary Poppins
what is happening just screw much I
don't oh yeah I'm The Blob one now it's
the best look at me that's their cool
Oh Oh No you waited for that I'm losing
my controller let's go in and wait
yeah okay what a great game Wow okay
grow wah I win
no no one won is he suck what does it
matter I'm going I'm going
you press x and y oh my god I'm doing
really well how am I good doing so good
Oh solid ass no that's you know milk
stuff know how I know this
ha ha ha no oh no aah come on
salad ass come on aah aah hey foot 5
Oh pushing me out I am I am he's nice
I know but I'm scared yeah hey sleepy
okay
he's any cute he's very cute when I'm
afraid that he's gonna jump on me in
attack week well this design of this
socks was inspired by slick face so this
should be your sock slipping thank you I
appreciate that that's very kind of you
oh thanks guys for supporting Buddha PI
socks I would wear them but I can't pass
hippie well well well
thank you for doing the foot challenge
yeah clap it up everyone clapping so
yeah check out happy socks I'm really
proud and happy to be working with them
it's a really cool brand I think you
guys will like it leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and as always
brofist yeah you have to come close
enough